démarche fluide et silhouette improbable
ce technicien géomètre est en plein
calcul dans son sac à dos cinq objectifs
orienter un peu partout et un scanner 3d
ici la haute technologie côtoie un canal
de berry vieillissant moi avec mon
instrument j'arrive à tirer 2 3 4 5 cm
de précision et qui permet d'utiliser
ses plans pour un groupe de travaux ou
quelque chose qui vraiment apporte une
précision extrême depuis le 10 octobre
les topographes de l'entreprise neuilly
travail à cartographier les berges du
canal de berry première étape pour
déterminer avec exactitude les
spécificités du terrain c'est une
mission en deux étapes
c'est à dire que nous avions une
acquisition sur le terrain donc on
capture on le réel ce qu'il y a autour
du canal les berges les arbres etc et
ensuite dans ce second plan une seconde
étape des calculs au bureau les 190 km
du canal de berry dans le cher sont
désormais cartographier un travail
indispensable pour lancer les appels
d'offres en janvier prochain
maintenant on passe en phase
opérationnelle
alors il ya une différence entre le
trait de crayon sur une cartographie qui
pouvait être ancienne et puis maintenant
la réalité du terrain
on a vécu par exemple des inondations au
mois de juin les inondations ont
peut-être un petit peu et sur moi-même
abîmé des berges et on sait à peu près
des endroits
donc c'est très important d'avoir la
réalité du terrain de façon à vraiment
être recadré par rapport aux futurs
travaux
coût des travaux 20 millions d'euros
premiers coups de pelle au printemps
prochain avec pour ambition de rejoindre
le parcours de la loire à vélo en 2025